[Music]
your grandparents they created something
extraordinary they were Fearless enough
to believe that the world is so much
more vast than we could possibly imagine
what's Monarch monsters are an
inescapable reality that we must learn
to
survive you know these things existed
this is your
legacy world is on fire something
happened that honor didn't want us to
know
about it's so map yeah but what is it a
map we can do this together we can
figure it
out I'm not taking orders from Monarch
anymore time to Cowboy
Up we are looking at a wave of Titan
events threatening the lives of 7
billion she what if the three could save
the 7
[Music]
billion